this is lucy james speaking for
alessandra for larry
now in this guide i'm gonna break down
seven essential tips for getting started
in mortal shell
and i'm gonna do it without mentioning
dark souls once
except for that mention right there the
swampy forest of fulgrim
serves as your hub which connects to the
three core dungeons in mortal shell
and it can be surprisingly easy to get
lost in its labyrinthine structure
early on in the game you'll arrive at
the fulgrim tower in addition to being
the place to swap shells and weapons
it also houses many of mortal shells
npcs
including a merchant sesta ganesa who
can upgrade your shells
and a workbench to improve your weapons
secrets items and dungeons are all
accessible the more you explore fulgrim
and be sure to explore these smaller
tunnels as they can help you skip
different areas and make your journey
from point a to point b
easier also keep an eye out for large
stone tablets
which you can read for lore and which
hold clues about hidden spots
while you'll face many monsters
throughout the game there are still
several friendly faces to find in
fulgrim who will have your back
the most important ally you have in your
adventure is sister ganesa
not only will she upgrade your shells
but she will also fill you in on some
crucial details
about the game's world to help offer
context and perspective
even giving you clues on where to go
next if you max out a particular shell's
upgrades
she'll instead sell you useful
consumables
there's also an easily missed vendor at
the top of the tower near its bell
who will sell weapon upgrades and a
special kit that gets you one of the
only ranged weapons in the game
don't miss them at the beginning of
mortal shell you'll familiarize yourself
with the protagonist
known as the foundling the foundling
isn't too resilient in a fight which
means they'll die
in only one hit to overcome this the
foundling can possess the bodies of long
deceased
warriors who have met their end in the
land of falgrim
allowing them to adopt their combat
skills and resilience
the first shell you'll find in the game
is harros a well-rounded warrior who has
fairly even health and stamina bars
eventually you'll find three other
shells that possess the familiar rpg
archetypes that focus on speed
resolve and defensive attributes even
before venturing into
the first dungeon you can find all four
characters
giving you options on how to proceed
with the rest of the game
some of these shells have advantages
over others so if you have a favorite
you're free to stick with them
throughout the game
still it's essential to learn what their
limits are and prioritize which skills
you should unlock
first in their skill menu if you feel
you want to switch over to a different
shell fast then be sure to keep an eye
out for items known as
effigies which can be used to switch
over to different characters while out
in the field
as you take on more foes and survive in
combat you'll begin to build up charges
of resolve
your pool of resolve which is located
just above your health meter
can be spent to engage special skills
and abilities in combat
in addition to a useful kick attack
which can be unlocked in your shell's
skill menu
you can also activate buffs for your
weapons you can also unlock specialized
weapon skills when upgrading your gear
letting you take down stronger prey or a
smaller group of enemies with ease
while you may feel inclined to use your
resolve when you've got it it's much
better to save them for when you need
them most
for instance the most useful repast
mechanic comes in clutch when you need
to restore health
but it costs a single bar of resolve to
use so be sure to keep track of your
resolve
while out in the field the most
invaluable skill that you'll need to
master is the ability to harden
this skill allows the foundling to
instantly turn to stone
making them and their shell invulnerable
to nearly every attack in the game
aside from certain grabs from the more
elite monsters
you can activate harden at any time even
mid attack
and this ability can be especially
useful when fighting some of the
aggressive and
quick enemies it's an incredibly useful
skill and when you learn the enemy's
attack patterns
you can actively use this knowledge
against them to set up some deadly
strikes
to win the fight
another incredibly useful defensive
skill is the parry
after making it to the fulgrim tower at
the beginning of the game you'll find a
large character called the old prisoner
shackled on the second floor
examining the item on the staircase next
to it will grant you the tarnished seal
once acquired you'll be able to use
parries in combat which can knock
enemies off balance
the tarnished seal opens up two
different forms of parrying the perfect
parry and the riposte
if you don't have any resolve you can
only use the perfect parry
this version requires some more precise
timing to nail but it will not only
knock
foes off balance after their standard
attack it will also restore
a single resolved charge if you have a
resolved charge then you can use the
riposte
this version of the parry will not only
stagger enemies but also opens them up
for a special attack
that restores some of your health
throughout your exploration of falgrim
you'll acquire a variety of items from
the ground
and from hidden chests but as you
examine these items you'll see that
you'll need to use them to learn of
their effects
each item has a familiarity level and
when you keep using that item
your character will gain knowledge about
it when you manage to max out
familiarity with one item after repeated
uses
you'll unlock its true potential you'll
also find that certain items like
healing mushrooms will respawn after a
certain time
so you'll rarely be out of some items
for long
maxing out familiarity can be great for
healing items and other objects that
offer buffs to your character
however some items present an initial
risk
for example the taskbar mushroom deals
poison damage to you when you first
use it once you max out familiarity with
the force it grants you temporary
immunity
to poison damage we'll have plenty more
to share on mortal shells so check out
our channel for our official review
as well as some neat guides on how to
unlock the game's hard mode
if you've got any more mortal shell tips
to share make sure to put them in the
comments below
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time
you